Star Wars Galaxies as a dangerous place
epic battles remote worlds strange
creatures and deadly threats at each
turn fire
a long time ago a group of young heroes
banded together to save the galaxy from
an evil empire a dark new threat
promises to destroy everything that they
fought for now it's time for a new
generation of Heroes you can accompany
me ray a scavenger searching for answers
and Finn a rogue stormtrooper looking
for something to fight for team up with
a mysterious droid named BBE these three
must make a choice continue their
journey alone or work together to defeat
the dark side
hey youtubers is charlie so Star Wars
behind-the-scenes special let's break it
down just a couple new things that we
haven't seen before the biggest thing is
general Hux Donal Gleason's character he
was a comic con but we haven't seen any
footage of his character we've only seen
pictures he's got like the Grand Moff
Tarkin of the new trilogy we don't
really have an organizational chart for
the first order yet but we know that
there's Captain phasma and then we know
that Finn is a rogue stormtrooper so
that that's why he knows about Luke
Skywalker I kind of explained in my last
video I'll put a link for that in the
description but we also get a better
look at this alien which has appeared in
promotional photos before but we've
never actually seen him on screen which
is every time they released a new clip
it seems like we see a new creature and
it's so awesome to see how much is this
is full-on puppetry that they're not
turning these into purely CG aliens the
exception I explained is Maz Kanata and
anti circuses character those two people
are heavily mocap just because of the
way their bodies work but we also get a
look at some of the new Star Destroyers
which you know are heavily influenced by
the aesthetic of classic Star Destroyers
the way mark hamill put it is that
everything is the same but everything
has changed in that that's always
confusing when people say that it just
means that design has evolved the most
identifiable expression of that is the
way stormtrooper helmets have changed
just because even if you've never heard
of star wars before like you recognized
the stormtrooper helmet and if you don't
live in the UK they do something special
called the children in need is this big
charity drive they do every year this
year they did a star wars-themed one
Martin Freeman was a part of it they did
a bunch of funny clips ah first you
shall not to miss don't eliza button
chris he can yes of course it I know
it's more Yoda I can do her lord I can I
do can speak it like this your mouth
okay no no no no no speak it watch me
lift our two with my mind this should be
good
look nothing's happening we just get
past yes okay I don't have Jedi powers
you may pop you may don't forget but we
are now slowly entering the one month
window for the movie coming out so
hopefully you guys have your tickets
speaking of which congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner it's two
free imax tickets to the force awakens
is it's like a gift certificate so you
can buy the tickets Austin trick a lot
be sure to private message me on the
back end of my channel so I get your
contact info and I will continue doing
Star Wars ticket giveaways as we go on
we'll probably get a new clip every week
so no worries plenty more giveaways
what's going to happen next is I have a
couple videos i'm finishing up we have
Doctor Who I have some new flash stuff
on posting this weekend so plenty of
crazy stuff and Sunday will still be
Game of Thrones Walking Dead just like
normal we're almost everybody so if you
haven't started yet just start flipping
out right now it's completely acceptable
to flip out over Star Wars why goes wait
for my next video to post you can click
here and here for the last couple of
Star Wars trailers that I posted thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight me
mini me